hello everyone and welcome to uh some
more daily rapid action on leeches I
actually thought about skipping today as
I didn't get all that much sleep my
daughter woke me up at 3:00 a.m. and
I've been awake ever since but um yeah I
thought it' be also fun to see how sleep
deprivation uh can uh maybe influence us
when we when we try to calculate lines
so it should be should be a lot of fun
uh so let's continue 10 minutes per
player again I'm doing it this way I'm
not clicking on the 10 plus something
because I'm adjusting the rating range I
want to play against high rated
opponents that's why I do it like this
see this is zero minus and I allow it my
opponents to be over 500 rating points
higher rated than me I would allow more
but leas caps it at 500 although I would
uh lose pretty much every game if um
alicias allowed more so let's continue
we are currently at
2213 and uh hopefully we can uh slowly
but surely reach that 2300 and maybe
even Beyond so let's check it out
probably we're getting the black pieces
this game as we got two white pieces for
the for the two previous games so let's
see uh what we
get uh let's uh all
right 880,000 players currently playing
surely we will we will get an opponent
someone is uh someone is probably
yearning for for a rapid game right
about now somewhere in the World we'll
see who it
is no still still
searching that's quite quite
odd uh let's just repeat that yeah 10
minutes per play everything is fine
let's do it yeah okay there we go uh and
our opponent is uh super 83 from Russia
so yeah we get the black pieces we'll
see what he does uh on e4 we're still
going to go for the for the hyper
accelerated Dragon like we've been doing
so far in the past previous videos and
on D4 yeah okay so it's an E4 we're
going to stick to this uh for those of
you who are maybe just joining us my
main line against E4 is the Scandinavian
uh but I thought this uh rapid action
that we are doing should
be uh a nice uh opportunity for us to
explore some other lines so let's go
Bishop to
G7 and uh do we go Bishop to G7 or is
this some sort of a yeah uh you know
when I started playing chess they always
um said that if your opponent plays C3
you should always start with the D5 so
I'm going to do that I don't know if it
works here point being that the C3
square has now been occupied and the
Knight will not have access to C3 so you
can even capture on um on D5 with the
queen so sort of like uh like playing
the
Scandinavian yeah but now I have to be
careful of all sorts of tricky stuff
like Pawn to
C4 so yeah
H uh we'll see we we'll see if it works
for
him yeah I never really studied uh
studied yeah he he goes for it right
away okay so we're going to play it
Force forcefully yeah okay let's capture
here he'll capture with the Knight
probably and we're going to go Knight to
C6 should we play Knight to C6 he has
Bishop to D3 then no he doesn't or maybe
he
does no he doesn't yeah let's go let's
go like
this yeah very very strange
stuff uh and yeah I've seen a lot of you
have been saying in the comments section
that I should be I should be playing
faster I shouldn't be talking while it's
my move uh that way my opponent uh gets
a lot of time but uh okay so how do we
how do we proceed here yeah okay this
Knight to C3 is actually very nice
ah what can we do what can we do that is
the
question yeah we go we're going to go
here uh sort of to avoid
any yeah he does have Knight to B5 then
maybe with the thread of
captus oh I think it's fine it is an odd
Square for the queen to be having in a
Sicilian Defense but yeah let's
see or is it my my sleep deprived brain
playing tricks on
me yeah so uh genuinely I like my
position if I can play Knight F6 and
castles if I cannot play that I don't
like my position so we'll see I I don't
know if there's anything that he can do
to actually prevent that like maybe he
goes for something like G3 even because
he might get a Tempo on my queen and put
some pressure on
C7 uh which could be could be annoying
but I don't think he has time for that
and we do have a threat here yeah just
Knight captures is the threat he's going
to lose a piece if he doesn't do
something so probably he just moves it
back I don't think he has the white
pieces I don't think he will be
interested in Knight captures and C6
says oh he he actually is interested in
that okay so why now we also don't have
to worry about any Knight jumps and he
will develop the bishop probably E2 and
F3 that that will make
sense and uh we're going to have to
decide whether we want to go Knight F3
and castles or do we have time to throw
in a rook B8 uh Rook B8 should always
always be played in such situations yeah
he's going to go for Bishop B2 and
F3
yeah okay so I don't think I have all
that much to worry about uh let's uh
let's go Rook B8
although I am putting it on the same
diagonal as the queen so G3 might be
annoying
here but yeah I can still capture I
don't see how it's supposed to be that
big of a
deal maybe I'm just uh you know maybe
I'm just tricking
myself
uh I don't know if I can trust my brain
right
now but yeah okay so he the depend at
nothing spectacular here we can even
play Rook capis it's even even this is
an option now yeah he will take I will
take with the queen uh he will take I
will take with the bishop with check
pick up the Rook so we can trade on
completely everything here the question
is do I want to do that or do I have
anything better if I if I can do that uh
I don't know if I'm missing something
here yeah I think it's actually
perfectly fine but he will take this
Pawn at the end of the line so we're
going to have equal material
yeah but I don't think we have anything
better and he's going to be left with
the past a pawn so we're going to have
to fight against
that so captures captures we're going to
play captures with Check Pro does he
capture if he doesn't capture we we just
take the queen so he captures Bishop
captures with check probably he blocks
yeah if he moves the king then he loses
castling privileges uh and he gets the
pawn back and if he blocks with the
bishop he can't take the pawn so I think
it's actually
fine yeah let's do it spent quite a bit
of time on this
uh I don't want to I don't want to not
play
it if it's if it's if it's
okay I am playing Black here okay maybe
this is uh trading down a bit too
early uh but we'll
see
we'll see what it
does Mr super 83 from
Russia and yeah I I'm also again I'm
making some lunch so yeah a nice rapid
game is is basically just enough time
for the for my meal to get
ready hope it doesn't get overcooked so
we should also also hurry up a little
bit uh but yeah should be okay
so yeah uh haven't really thought this
true brilliantly he will he will either
go for the pawn and uh lose castling
privileges or he will block with the
bishop and then not take the pawn I
would go for the pawn
uh no he actually resigned
here he actually resigned here did
I why did he resign
here did I miss something was my was my
move so good that even I didn't
understand it uh but yeah seems like
today I'm going to I'm going to be on
time for my meal yeah so yeah let's
analyze this real
quickly uh okay so this is perfectly
fine okay yeah Queen captures D5 okay
Bishop G7 he played C4 I play Queen E4
check uh yeah interestingly I'm playing
all the top engine moves yeah okay
Knight H6 okay so this is what the
engine uh wants us to play obviously
followed by Knight to F5 okay we played
Knight here play Knight C3 I played
Queen here he captured I captured he
played Bishop B2 still this Knight to H6
move okay something to remember uh maybe
uh I'm I'm going to check after the game
you know some games that were played in
uh in this line uh if it's really that
important I played Rook here yeah Rook
here obviously the engine doesn't like
he just says yeah castle and give up the
pawn point being that if he castles and
I take the pawn bishop F3 okay he goes
after the pawn and now uh he says
that yeah okay so obviously we can't
take the Knight because captures and he
has to go I have to go here and queen
queen d8 is Checkmate uh but can it
still be played yeah but obviously I
have to play with Queen to C7 as the
engine is telling us and then he just
keeps harassing my queen yeah that's the
reason yeah see very nice now again if I
capture he captures and checkmates me
and uh if we go E5 yeah then he goes
back okay I go back and now Knight E4
and he says that this is better for
him okay I can believe that yeah double
attack on the Knight and he I also lose
castling privileges captures captures
King goes here yeah this is a the engine
says Okay Plus 1.2 for white so maybe it
can still be played like I say it
doesn't matter what the engine says it's
either winning or it's not but uh yeah
this was obviously very good for him so
Rook to B8 not uh really not a threat uh
objectively but you know for rapid game
yeah it's hard to maybe take advantage
of this he played this and now yeah he I
play Rook captures and and he just
resigned uh but yeah so what uh what did
I miss here
like yeah that's what okay and okay it's
because I capture a free rook that's the
point oh so I'm just up a piece okay so
my sleep deprived brain actually
miscalculated that I'm going to be up a
piece here uh but I I still won the game
so that's
that's really
weird uh but yeah my opponent calculated
it precisely and he uh he he he decided
to resign here yeah very
nice yeah very nice wow so what yeah uh
but obviously don't try to play serious
chess if if you're sleep deprived um you
know I could have just as easily lost
this game I could could have
miscalculated that I'm going to be up a
piece when in fact I would be down a
piece here yeah it kind of went my way
uh so once again hope you guys enjoyed
it probably if I if I manage to get some
rest we're going to play another one but
probably I'm just going to continue
tomorrow uh so thank you all I will see
you soon have an excellent rest of your
day and also suggest some openings that
you want to see I'm I'm honing my skill
and I will try to use some of the
openings that you guys mentioned in the
comment section below uh see you
soon